howdy-ho neighbor he knows welcome to
another episode of honest trailer
commentaries in this case we're talking
unbreakable is line and which I'm told
us from kimmy schmitt this is a show
where we talk about the other show
that's on the other channel so go watch
that first or not come back and you'll
see our thoughts about unbreakable in
full detail and if you stick around to
the end you'll see some deleted scenes
and cut jokes that didn't make it in
guys I hadn't seen unbreakable in 20
years or something I liked it it's been
a while yeah I I love this movie I
really really like it a lot and I really
want glass to be a good movie yeah I am
this did get me I guess retro actively
even more excited for glass after the
the second trailer came out look it's a
mopey film it's not gonna it's on the
slow side but it's a slow burn it is and
it's sweet it's one of those movies that
plays completely differently now than it
did when it came out because when it
came out it's hard it's one of the
things to put in context cuz I saw it in
theaters when it came out it would bleed
had happened yeah an x-men had happened
that year yeah and that was as far as
contemporary Superman or a cowboy movies
that weren't Batman or Superman that was
it yep yeah and the the watching it now
I think it seems obvious that it's a
comic book movie but back then the
audacity to think that M night Shyamalan
would have followed up The Sixth Sense
was a comic book movie was like madness
so at the end when it's revealed like
this is this this is a superhero you
know villain origin story like oh my god
of course it is how did I not see that
I think everyone's now so trained to
just know everything about it and and
and the concept of doing a superhero
movie was just like oh yeah it's a
comfort movie but at the time it did not
know not see that coming it was
advertised as like an M night Shyamalan
movie in the sense that like this is a
thriller it's a mystery and you won't
believe that ending like I remember that
being in the promotional materials for
it making no mention of comic books or
superheroes or anything no no which
makes the bill
glass sort of ironic because now
everyone's just treating glasses like
like they would treat any other
superhero movie like here's a video of
15 things you need to know about the
unbreak of us which is the exact
opposite of how we were given on break
we'll even split it's got a rocky
relationship trailer that he doesn't
have on a wedding ring so he must have
moved to New York for that security job
after all
number two abuse is a common theme in
this franchise number six
Easter Egg for the creepy guy that broke
into those people's house murdered the
parents and kept the children hostage
confirmed yeah yeah look it's not a
perfect film especially you got to be in
a mood to to sit through this because
this movie I mean this movie is
literally all mood it's a mood piece you
know yeah everyone is in a big mood mood
in that atmospheric mood Bruce Willis
never gets above a four on the energy
level no things being generous he never
really dials it above before and but I
think Sam Jackson like it's a perfect
counterpart to him like it is a really
good match of hero and villain it is
it's yeah it's weird cuz it's it's all
the stuff that also doesn't work in a
bunch of other Schemmel on films at all
kind of monotone it's liberating the
dialogues weird and clunky it's super
atmospheric like it's a little up its
own butt but I don't know just in this
case he shook up the Voodoo bones and
threw a minute and it worked and it I
don't know what it is because it's the
same elements I think being a comic book
story happening the comic story lends
itself to that like you're willing to
indulge in a little bit of like
heightened or rather like lowered
reality like yeah this would be more of
a weird tone because it isn't a world
like ours but is it yeah but yes when
you have a superhero in his weaknesses
water and the context of the movie
you're like what is this superhero
that's
weakness that makes sense in signs it's
like why would you come to a play why
would you come to a person that doesn't
make sense to me why you see the like
descent to earth oh man alright let's
watch who's gonna say science will do
science eventually but we talked about
doing science for this one we didn't
because wouldn't make sense I guess that
really wouldn't make six wheelers we're
gonna - we have no other choice
after his breakout hit but before we had
to break up with him Hamelin was still
our I just wrote in the script a bad
clip from last airbender here yes which
one you said any of that random what I
said close your eyes and point and I
said I do like the one where he says
bring hill of your elbow bringing all
your help oh yeah anyways Shyamalan was
still unbreakable you like split and
after someone explained why Bruce Willis
was in it
you keep meaning to check out
unbreakable the atmospheric thinking
man's comic book film that M night kept
insisting would possibly G can you back
up to that shot and the kid playing with
the action figures is that a cardboard
cutout of David or is he is that Willis
I think I think he's so still that he
looks like a cardboard cutter but that's
him okay well yeah real low energy you
shot James McAvoy Oh God if that's the
twist and he's also David Dunn is it
that the exact plot of the adaptation of
Donald Kaufman's script the detective
and there's this chase between man and
horse yes or no train and horse yeah
alright keep going well we've seen him
running like a horse yeah then that kept
not happening which in hindsight was a
really good thing because he had a lot
of crap to get out of the system first
Bruce Willis shines as David done a
detached middle-aged man who doesn't
take full advantage of his talents and
just kind of mopes around even though
he's got it all aka Bruce Willis if you
haven't seen that clip it was in the
screenings one year yeah we try to
feature it wherever we can yeah and God
bless this this this British gentleman
it was on the other side of this
interview that is a junket for read too
and Bruce Willis completely unbidden
decides to explain the home just like
he's like the fun part well part so
what's making the movie we did that
months ago this this is all parts over
this is what works over this is this is
selling what's him from weeds
mary-louise Parker he's Parker yeah it's
doing her best she's like she really
isn't helping that much because she says
yeah the fun parts over yeah and then
guys like really oh well I quite like
this movie and that's where this I quite
like the music oh yeah oh did you oh oh
yeah yeah yeah oh did you like it did
you like the movie he's just like well
how would you tell people to see this
like I wouldn't what did you say I just
slashed my hose junkets aren't easy on
them I mean their lives are easy but
junkets is it's an entire day of acting
of pretending to be engaged and awake
and stuff yeah because they just sit
there in the chairs and they just roll
in one schmuck after the next for for as
long as it takes to get every single
outlet and they do it you know couple
days in a row you know Bruce Wallace he
doesn't have to do this no yeah which
which means he shouldn't have shown up
at the first place but the fact that he
is there and at the end of his rope
makes for some really funny junk and
every it's not just this British guy I
was looking at all the judgement
interviews from read to look at body
language both their arms like they're
like Team Rocket see they lucked out
because they're just like in a hotel
room which is mildly comfortable the the
junket for the nun was in an abandoned
convent in Mexico City and it was
freezing and raining and school like I
guess they weren't a-list enough to
[ __ ] about the fact yeah freezing to
death yeah they're probably in like well
they're not because he's like whatever
city they're in
Bruce is like I wish it was like
Istanbul this temples a nice place yes
some question about like have you ever
been somewhere he's like I wish I was in
Istanbul okay moving on let's keep going
sorry Bruce watch as this truly light is
turned upside down by Elijah price a
fragile obsessive who insists that
everyone likes comics the same way that
he does this is an art gallery my friend
and this is a piece of art and who's
prone to angry violent outbursts aka
modern-day comics fans to give us
they'll shake up David's midlife I'll
let the viewer determine what the
original line was for modern-day comics
fans and what we watered it down to I'll
just leave that in your brain it's not
an evening
keep playing oh yeah that's I didn't
write that draft they'll shake up
David's midlife crisis by discovering he
has the power to lift any weight lick
any toilet seat and pause for any amount
of time in the middle of a sentence I'm
so moving they're just props to a visual
possess Kevin email us inflames the
first morning that I can remember I came
up with a silly idea and nine times out
of ten were like love us great father I
do just want to talk about his powers
and him not getting sick you're ever in
his life mm-hmm and him not noticing
that until someone else pointed it out
not a cold not the flu but when you
don't know the difference I guess you
just always kind of done the dumps
everybody's always been he's always been
sleepwalking yeah but also like how
about this high school football player
college football players I'm like that
but ya never saw how much he could lift
never never threw some more weight on
never pushed it I guess if you're strong
and you're lifting weights and you're
like I'm strong then why why
more weights yeah I already got strong
okay you got her to get streaming this
is a guy who decided he was gonna leave
his wife because one day he was like oh
I didn't tell her about a nightmare I
had so I can't see him being a guy who's
like let me see how far I can push this
weight and really excel at things yeah
but also the wife being like he enjoy he
was a football player and that was a
complete deal-breaker for me football is
violent and he was a monster
yes yeah I made him give up his dreams
to be with me he didn't she didn't make
him he did it of his own volition right
you're right he didn't knew that it was
it was probably not going to be a
productive thing for him and he chose
her over football that's true I do I do
run that back but then you know come on
this is his dream it's not a healthy
relationship also was he just fake
limping for four months I guess we go to
go to doctors and being like no this is
real I think so yeah he was just fake
limping hmm lin-manuel Miranda did it
Teddy yeah do you see him on Graham
Norton no yeah he told his story he
wanted to get out of summer camp so he
fakes the spinal injury Wow Wow that's
real fun why do you go I don't want to
get out of summer camps if you hate
Lakes so much strap in for everything
you love about early Shyamalan like
clunky dialogue
you can't let bad things happen to good
people right that's your code right
that's the heroes code something about
water being scary I'm afraid of water
you have a weakness water do you
remember the story about the about the
boy that almost drowned in the pool and
a twist
pause person now there was a documentary
about Shyamalan where he talks about
drowning as a kid or almost drowning
mm-hmm which then turned out was a hoax
that M night Shyamalan came up with the
documentary was fake it was somebody
else's documentary but he was actually
involved in in on it
he never actually drowned so what how
weird is this but he's like making that
into his fake haunted that sounds about
right being it is more if I'm Jonas
twist or is that just gas lighting and
repeating something until it's true yes
I really don't I make a documentary
about that yeah cuz I was like I was
just looking into it like the water
thing comes up a lot it's like oh here's
this clip of him talking about this
drowning experience he had as a child
oh and then there's this article about
how this documentary is actually a
complete fake to like establish the
mythos of M night Shyamalan I mean he
was very particularly post unbreakable
pre lady in the water he was very
invested in maintaining and
manufacturing a certain mystique about
himself remember when you could do that
yeah that's not a thing anymore
no that's like that's all haha that's
how Hollywood operated on mystique from
like the 20s through this two years ago
that's when he's through Twitter
Hollywood operated completely on
mystique and you know you can't do it
any nope no man I saw I think I saw
eating cookies at a restaurant once
saves Madonna shattered yeah yeah you
eat cookies just like the rest of us can
you imagine if Keanu Reeves and eating
that sandwich would know Twitter and no
social media you should still have the
misty would be gone like every tears and
rain
yep okay you've got receipt coming the
first time there will be so obvious the
second time around you won't know how
you missed it they say this one has a
surprise ending I mean is it still a
twist if you're expecting a twist or is
the real twist knowing he knows you
think the twist is coming so he probably
won't do a twist then doing it with
anyway boom Shyamalan suppose so before
we expecting a twist for glass right
it's the end of a trilogy so it's kind
of tough to yeah I don't know what the
twist was leaning into something else
but I'm expecting it twist I don't even
know what glass is gonna be I also don't
know why I just sounded like Bobcat
Goldthwait for juice
I don't know what glass is supposed to
be like I don't think it's gonna be I'm
still doing it yeah I don't think it's
an ort
I don't I have no idea what to expect
from that movie hmm
that at the twister some trickery is
gonna be there will be severe but it's
gonna be some kind of trickery
tomfoolery some rugs will be pulled yeah
yeah I don't know what I don't know how
yeah but something but I'll be on edge
and I'll be like that guy in your
screening that went oh my god it happens
oh yeah is it gonna be something
terrible like they're gonna at the end
they're gonna zoom out there's gonna be
like a Kevin Feige guy and he's plotting
out the beats of it on the wall and he's
like pitching it to Disney and he's like
that's my shared universe and it's like
1998 no like comic book movies will
never work yeah yeah F - um I was
thinking that this would be the book
that M night Shyamalan wrote in lady in
the water that would inspire and it's
Paul Giamatti and the nymph or whatever
or Grendel snarks and those other things
in there the snark engulfs ya and M
nights reading it - Paul Giamatti and
then the wind blows and they both just
lift their throats yeah yeah they called
it a signs alien it kicks in the door
but he's dead cuz water because the
water and that's it yep you go you know
the salt so before you experience the
mind-blowing scale the next big comic
book movie dial things back like you
think it's gonna come out
for a superhero film that does it all
without CGI epic battles or sky beings
because sometimes all it takes to tell
an epic story is the power Oh process
behind this movie lot of stairs in it
time to bring it back it's so much
staring into the middle distance
[Music]
my favorites are the ones you think
we're gonna cut away probably just keep
going more stairs than this or of course
in the movie the piece of the walk
upstairs yeah
staring sigh hard Haley Joel Osment
brick man like this Plunkett and in West
Philadelphia wait all day the playground
was how he's been yeah there's like half
an idea completely written out weeks for
psychological care nice yeah brother man
who feels he feels people now what's
that Paz what's the threshold on is his
touching of criminality could he like
see me jaywalking this is why I'm so
scared of glass because those are the
conversations that I don't give a [ __ ]
about but those but they will happen in
earnest like what is can he lift a car
like yeah could could rescue man
whatever the hell good security guard
man defeat to spider-man and arm
wrestling match like he's gonna have to
that beast look scary like a dog he's
crawling on ceilings bedlam hey I just
want those things to stay away from
unbreakable I just it's it deserves to
be on its own terms but it is getting
progressively more comic book II yeah
you know he's developing his powers so
maybe he can touch felonies now but he
can move his way down what does he gets
more sensitive to my fractions but I'm
assuming he's now a master of his powers
been 18 years so he should be a yeah he
should be a master of whatever right he
does crime crime field fondly there's a
word for it now I I don't remember it at
all there's like there is like a weird I
telekinetic touch
or telepathic touch word and it's gone
from here that's okay well let's finish
you better not be jacking off to the
Japanese comics I swear to God it is
called hentai and it is art good day sir
there you go I'll leave you with that
yeah let's roll right into some deleted
scenes just do it
hit it stare ease unbreakable he alive
damn it Bruce Willy you're a mean one
mr. glass lone wolf all prone plotting
Purple People Mangler my wife Claire
under my very strange or agreed on that
sometimes we know we're not gonna get
dorks
now Robin Wright was in that's even more
high per class as if it were called
unbreaking to electric Boogaloo the real
mystery of this movie is the lack of
decent newspaper editors they ran the
same headline three times and they
misspelled except Gotham is all excited
can't enjoy the movie now no ruin but
there is a Robin rights in this film as
is the guy who plays a Doug Stamper and
how some guess he's the doctor in the
emergency room that would be a huge
twist in glasses if they all team up to
just beat Frank underwear into a pulp
that's how they just that's how they
discover what Kevin Spacey's been up to
is David Dunn actually walked by and
like brushed him on the shoulder
yeah attack yeah more thoughts on them
break well I liked it yeah it's good
Moody didn't I say yeah yeah it's a
period piece for me mmm III am curious
how people that see it now react to it
yeah yes it does it does read and feel
different now in the 1819 years later
than it did in 2000 when there were 98
percent fewer comic-book movies and when
this actually seems like an audacious
yeah yeah and just like little 2000 isms
of you know the score the techno techno
score which I love it
her oddities in the show matrix so this
is so just wheelhouse like I was at the
right age to see this one where I was
like these can do this yeah yeah just
and I know it's a lot of staring in a
lot of atmosphere but just as so much of
it again just works for me like him like
sliding the newspaper to the kid just to
like to confirm that he's right it's
like a good moment yeah there was not a
small amount of disappointment with this
film when it came out people were
disappointed they wanted a bigger twist
I'm saying there was a lot of people
that were expecting like a mind-blowing
and a sixth sense type experience and it
was so underplayed and subtle that when
it got to the end people were like
that's it yeah right do that every time
he should have done one at all for his
second film so that people stopped
thinking of him as the twist back twist
my studio yeah well his career is a big
you and now I think it's it's not back
to a sixth sense but it's close we're
gay I'm now excited to see his next
movie and it took a lot of work but here
we are yeah he's a weird dude there's
always gonna be some weird stuff in his
movies weird side plots or rapping kids
or stuff that you're like what why is
this in here but generally he's doing
well yeah so cheers to you yes have a
cookie on me M night and cheers to you
viewer we hope you'll be back for more
similar content then you just received
for next week's which is a holiday
themed but kind of late to the party is
that next week I don't even know I don't
know what you're talking about
oh yes it's holiday themed yeah so enjoy
that
yeah and enjoy that little tease you'll
pick it up later okay
and we'll see you next week bye guys
you
[Music]